nicht heute eine nachricht ersetzt und
ja ich muss auch sagen verstört denn
schweden hat den moderner impfstoff für
junge erwachsene unter 30 jetzt erst mal
ausgesetzt also wenn man unter 30 ist
bekommt man jetzt erst mal nicht mehr
moderner verabreicht dänemark hat gleich
gezogen da ist aber bei den unter 18
jährigen also die unter 18-jährigen
dänemark kriegen nicht mehr moderner
verabreicht und den schweden die unter
30 jährigen ich habe natürlich dann muss
ich gestehen direkt in der sekunde eine
freundin von mir gedacht die den
modernen impfstoff verabreicht bekommt
haben in deutschland zum glück hatten
die auch nichts denn das muss man jetzt
hier sagen das sind sehr sehr geringer
teil hatte nebenwirkungen des wegen der
jetzt erst mal ausgesetzt wird aber es
gibt halt ein sehr geringes risiko von
herzmuskelerkrankungen und da ist jetzt
schweden und dänemark einfach mal vorweg
gegangen und haben ihn bis dezember
erstmal ausgesetzt und was wünsche ich
mir von deutschland oft dass deutschland
anderen weg gegangen hat schweden und
dänemark oft kann ich das schlecht jetzt
finde ich es auch schlecht und ich finde
deutschland sollte folgen deutschland
muss auch moderner prüfen lassen ich
möchte aber noch einmal ganz klar
erwähnen bevor ich die runde eröffnen es
wurde wirklich damit hier keine
panikmache entsteht in dänemark und
schweden auch nur ein sehr geringer teil
hatte diese herzmuskelerkrankungen des
risikos nach wie vor bei moderner sehr
gering laut den neuesten meldungen aus
schweden und dänemark trotzdem finde ich
deutschland sollte sich anschließen
deutschland muss moderner überprüfen
lassen also wenn wir was in deutschland
können lena dann glaube ich ist es
prüfen ja wie oft habe ich den satz in
letzter zeit gehört das müssen wir
prüfen
ich glaube das unentwegt in deutschland
alles geprüft wird 10 mal 20 mal und
wenn wir überhaupt ein problem in der
korona krise hatten dann war es dass wir
zu viel geprüft haben zu vorsichtig
waren zu langsam waren zu viel angst
hatten zu viel panik gemacht haben jetzt
kommst du um die ecke und sagst da ist
schon wieder sieht schon wieder die
nächste angst auf vor dem impfstoff ich
würde mich hier live sofort mit moderner
impfen lassen heute abend noch mal ich
finde wir haben eine zu vorsichtige
diskussion auch um eine dritte impfung
das müsste ja eigentlich auf den tisch
warum impfen wir nicht längst
flächendeckend moderner als dritte
impfung und wie gesagt in deutschland
haben wir viel zu viel angst verbreitet
waren viel zu vorsichtig in dieser krise
und ich habe volles vertrauen dass
unsere behörden wenden überhaupt eines
können dann können die prüfer
entschweben bitte jetzt bayern tag
anstelle davon verabreicht werden und
auch dänemark hat das gerade gemacht ich
muss ehrlich sagen ich sehe das anders
ich hatte beide ersten also die erste
und zweite impfung hatte ich mit bayern
tag deswegen ich glaube ich weiß gar
nicht meins dritten dann überhaupt
moderner wählen könnte weil man schon
bald ich glaube man bleibt dann
wahrscheinlich bei den gleichen
impfstoff aber ich sehe das nicht so ich
meinen schweden ist ja nicht das land
was alles überprüft hat in schweden
waren die hallen offen die kinder konfus
beispielen während in deutschland die
kinder vom fußballplatz nur träumen
konnten also schweden ist für mich nicht
das land das panik land was alles direkt
überprüft überhaupt und der ist ja aber
genau deswegen muss es doch für
deutschland jetzt ein signal sein okay
vielleicht schließen wir uns mal an wie
siehst du das denn ja aber die ständige
impfkommission ist ja oder auch die
ehemals auf europäischer ebene war auch
meinung teile ich mit teilweise auf
jeden fall das eigentlich dort sehr
seriös geprüft wurde dass es eigentlich
auch gar keine ratschläge aus anderen
ländern bedurfte sondern dass da die
deutschen fachleute eigentlich extrem
gut geprüft haben sehr gewissenhaft
eigentlich die themen angegangen sie
haben ja schon geimpft haben haben wir
immer noch geprüft ja das muss man auch
mal sie also von daher glaube ich aber
das thema panik und du hast selbst
gesagt du willst keine panik jetzt
verbreiten aber wir haben ja heute beim
thema panik auch schon wieder neues
gehört also not a wiener der rk ii chef
der ja in gewisser weise schon wieder
neue panik auch verbreitert die man
plötzlich gesagt hat ja zwischen corona
und grippe gebe es doch sehr sehr viele
gemeinsamkeiten also hat die grippe
quasi auf eine stufe mit corona gehoben
was eigentlich bisher immer nur
querdenker sogenannte querdenker gemacht
haben ich glaube da wird er wieder neue
panik geschürt und das ist schlecht aber
jan sagen wir jetzt mal nur noch ein
fall moment wird hier auf jeden der sich
nicht impfen lassen will das wird ja
gesellschaftlich ist ja die
gesellschaftliche ächtung ja wirklich
schon bei 100 prozent was ich mich aber
jetzt frage schweden und dänemark sagen
es gibt im geringen risiko bei den unter
30 jährigen ist waren wir vor allem
männer betroffen seltene
herzmuskelentzündungen das ist für mich
dann keine panikmache sondern finde ich
schon okay dann müssen wir überlegen vor
allem auch bei den jüngeren kindern u18
wo er vieles auch symptomatisch verläuft
und da finde ich jetzt schon dass man
überlegen muss okay
auch risiken gegeneinander weiß ich
zumindest hätte ich die debatte gerade
schon gerne in deutschland wie siehst du
es denn ich finde also es zeigt erst mal
dass es nicht die wissenschaft gibt weil
die wissenschaftler in anderen ländern
sind ja nicht weniger seriös deswegen
ist es eigentlich schon erstaunlich dass
in verschiedenen ländern verschiedene
ergebnisse
herauskommen
deswegen ist es für mich eigentlich eher
ein signal dass man es auf jeden fall
umso mehr untersuchen sollte jede
unterschiedlichere ergebnisse
wissenschaftler auch er in studien dann
herausfinden
natürlich ist es immer noch eine seltene
geschichte das ist auch gut so das würde
jetzt auch in vielen studien schon
geprüft aber nichtsdestotrotz wenn bei
der impfung die wahrscheinlichkeit höher
ist als bei anderen gewöhnlichen
impfungen sollte das schon grund zur
annahme sein oder grund zur sorge sein
dass man das ganze noch einmal
überprüfen sollte und wie du auch schon
gesagt hast ich finde die impfquote
finde ich persönlich gar nicht so gering
weil kinder sind darunter ich glaube wir
haben fast 15% kinderanteil oder unter
18-jährige sage ich mal erstens und
zweiten zweitens werden die genesenen
fast nie mit in diese rechnung
einbezogen aber ist unser problem
eigentlich jetzt dass wir zu wenig
impfstoff haben oder ist unser problem
eigentlich dass ich zu wenig menschen in
deutschland noch impfen lassen wenige
modelle haben eben auch ein verzichtete
missionar wir haben schon im sommer
darauf hat genau das vielleicht die
lieferung ist das problem habe ich eher
auf wirklichen andere ist also die dänen
die schweden die können ja in dem fall
machen was sie wollen unsere fachleute
bin mir sicher dass die das auf weiter
mit der hand zum erschrecken oder dem
was wir in deutschland haben ist ja eher
dass das offenbar die impfquote noch
nicht so hoch ist wie man sich das
eigentlich gewünscht hat das also
eigentlich die die maßnahmen verstärken
werden müssten zugucken wie bekommen wir
eigentlich noch mehr menschen oder zu
einem pieks oder den pigs in die arme
der menschen und ich hab da ist das
thema moderner drei oder vier fünf
monaten geimpft ja und ich habe für mich
eigentlich damit abgeschlossen und es
muss jeder wissen es gibt immer ein
kleines risiko 100 prozent sicherheit
gibt es nie ja und wenn man eben
ich glaube dass die nebenwirkungen
geringer sind wie eine krankheit ja wie
ein ausbruch hatten sie nebenwirkungen
hatte etwas wie
keine nebenwirkungen und mein ganzer
freundes bekanntenkreis die verwandten
auch nicht ja und ich weiß noch nicht
mal mehr jetzt mit was ich mich habe in
vielen lang oder sogar komisch
normalerweise kommen immer visum starkes
symbol welches
die immobilien gerade karl hat jeder
gefragt worin siehst du denke es ist
johnson der praktischen da muss ich nur
einmal hin aber dann hatte ich schon ein
anderes und ich meine für mich ist immer
das risiko geringer als dann nachher
nutzen und drittes mal impfen lassen
würden sie sich auch wahrscheinlich oder
einfach noch mal als zuhörer erreicht
mich weil ich ein abenteurer bin ja und
weil ich nicht krank sein möchte okay
aber wer ist gedacht sie ahnt man auf
den wenn sie in die andere ich kann ich
habe verständnis wenn die leute sich
nicht impfen lassen wollen und jeden tag
ich habe mich so oft essen lassen dass
ich jetzt froh bin dass ich mir wenig
sind immer jeden tag testen lassen muss
für irgendeinen job also war es auch
eine impfung für die freiheit ja absolut
ja kann ich euch sagen und ich habe das
risiko dass ich nebenwirkungen habe
einfach runtergeschluckt ja wie ich so
oft im leben aber wo ist denn der
impfstoff für die dritte impfung ich
habe das schon mal kurz gesagt
eigentlich müssten doch jetzt einmal in
altenheimen müssten da müssen die busse
hinfahren und sofort wieder die dritte
impfung anbieten in den sozialen berufen
wo die impfung eben schon lange her ist
wo im januar im februar im märz geimpft
wurde dann müssten jetzt massiv die
teams reingehen und sofort wieder den in
schweden liegen gebliebenen moderner
impfstoff impfen ja das fehlt an debatte
meiner ansicht nach
hunderttausende von touristen die nicht
verimpft
yavuz die reale ende wusste debatte um
die dritte impfung führen wir bisher gar
nicht also das ist doch jetzt also wir
brauchen
so ist liegt weniger prüfen ja einfach
machen es ist erstmal weihnachten machen
wie eine live im funk demnächst hier das
habe ich versprochen hans ulrich jörges
nicht werden als beim film nach tricks
geben lassen
ich habe das gefühl du bist auch dabei
hier live würde es auch ein paar blieb
ich hoffe dass irgendwann das ding
wieder an dynamik gewinnt wie so vieles
im leben und dass dann der drops
gelutscht ist
[Musik]